this is a production of Cornell
University
okay kind of lonely up here after the
whole scholarship Pam is cleared up
someone walked in right now they think I
smell really bad you all just like
cleared out the front rows so I want to
talk to you today about food the back of
the t-shirts say 4h feeding the future
why does that matter why do we need to
feed the future why does food man I need
to have a question how many of you in
the last 24 hours have taken part in an
agricultural act razor that's awesome I
don't normally get that that's a lot of
ants keep your heads up per second I got
it what was your agricultural act in a
pic t-shirt ate dinner that's a good
answer right now I want to hear some
other answers what did what did you do
this is farming definitely an
agricultural act at one more hand I'm
cultural act what you do blended
mushroom certainly an agricultural act
gonna get back get back to your answer
she said she ate dinner what's
agricultural about that kid farms you
can play anything she water anything but
let's say another race I had how many
people have eaten food from last 24
hours
there we go there we go that's that's
why food matters because of her answer
right there because eating is an
agricultural act food matters because we
eat three times a day and three times a
day we're connecting for the land and
sometimes that connection that
relationship is a really really good one
it's healthy it's clean sometimes it's a
really really bad it's a twisted
relationship food is at the heart of the
biggest crises we face today take three
the three of the big crisis we face
today the health crisis the economic
crisis and the energy crisis in 2009
more people than ever before in history
died of starvation that same year 2009
more people than ever before in history
were diagnosed as morbidly obese as an
imbalance four of the top 10 killers in
the united states are diet related
diseases stroke cancer heart disease
type 2 diabetes food is at the heart of
the health crisis every year we spend
100 billion dollars on dyer related
preventable illnesses over 10 years if
that number doesn't increase at all as a
trillion dollars on preventable die
related illnesses and that's that cliff
that brings us the economic crisis we're
spending a huge amount of money on a
food system that doesn't work and then
finally the energy crisis the biggest
contributor to greenhouse gases in our
economic sector is the food system the
food industry there's a great story
about about how we move food around the
world every year we import 50,000 boxes
of cookies for Denmark which kind of
makes sense because you know the days
they know how to make cookies they eat a
lot of tea they probably were really
good
recipe for cookies so it's okay we
employ these fifty thousand boxes of
cookies from Denmark area but at the
same time every year we export 40,000
boxes of sugar cookies to demo the guy
who the World Bank suggested that maybe
we just swap recipes we're spending a
huge amount of energy on shipping food
back and forth all over the world so and
all of those prices fit under one
heading 1 let's close to home for me on
the most important language of the
environmental crisis and again that's
why food matters three times a day we
food and three times a day by eating
foods were connected to the land and
sometimes we're doing that by eating a
carrot that our friends grew for us it's
backyard and sometimes we're doing that
by eating a tomato that was grown in
children so that's why the Food Matters
put on a backup fit there's this whole
you're spending the next few days
talking about feeding the future and
you're talking about your careers and
you're looking forward to the future
hopefully you're learning with some
skills that you'll take home and use to
change your community and ultimately the
people that leave this room in this
conference are going to think about
changing their communities and changing
the world I was in the garden the other
day at garden and a little kid it was a
fourth grade he looked up to me I don't
know we're out of blue and he said he
said can one kid change the world and I
really don't to say partly because I'm
used to getting questions like how big
is an inch or is this a tomato plant and
so the more like changing the world
question kind of threw me for a loop but
also I realized that no one's ever asked
me that before I'm talking all the time
about making change and no one's ever
asked me if one kid you change the world
so I haven't been able to stop thinking
about that question over the last
I want to tell you a story and my story
is really about a story about a guy but
it doesn't start in a farm or in the
kitchen or anywhere else you might
expect someone talking about food and
Barbara my story about a garden starts
at a pond near my house I grow I live in
rural western Massachusetts and as a kid
I spent all my time at this I'm
collecting fog frogs and all kinds of
weird insects and I fell in love with
the natural world and as I got older it
became a love of biology of studying of
experimenting of collecting weird weird
alien sex and doing weird weirder things
with them lost a lot of friends that way
and and then in eighth grade I saw a
movie called an inconvenient truth which
some of you may have heard of and I saw
a movie and I realized that all these
things I cared so much about were in
Paris or in danger and and so coming
into high school I was all worked up I
love the natural world so much and it's
all in danger what am I going to do when
come to high school I save the world
it's gonna be great then my other
brother gave me a book called a
durometer boys dilemma and the omniverse
lemon and this book was about food and
it was about how farms exactly three
things I talked about before how farms
were at the heart of these issues now
the way we grow food when it's done
badly destroyed the planet when it's
done well can save and so I came into
high school realizing that food could
save the world and and what happened was
I was a freshman in high school you guys
all some of you may be freshman in high
school some of you may
Finn freshman in high school maybe even
a few you're going to be freshman high
school when you're a freshman you're
ready to make make two big things and so
I had this idea that I was going to get
all the food from I cafeterias become
from local farms and when I was driving
by my school I notice all the land
around their school and I think I'll
maybe we have a little garden like maybe
the size of you know a quarter of this
this stage and I started talking to some
friends these two girls Natalie and
Sarah and the more we talked more we
thought why not make it a bigger garden
like a really big guy like maybe even a
farm and well instead of getting all the
food from local farms why don't we just
grow all the food for our cafeterias and
that's what we did and so much happened
so fast that sometimes I forget the most
important thing that happened was well
we face it a lot of doubt because we
were high schoolers and you got to know
high schoolers we're lazy we can't
follow through and everything on
anything we we play video games all day
right we don't do anything right so now
so
so we faced a lot of doubt because we
were warned that the school committee
would tell us we couldn't use the land
we call farmers who said we were biting
off way more than we could chew we're
told we were getting in over our heads
but despite all that out we did
something important we decided we were
going to do it no matter what no matter
what people said we decided we're going
to grow this garden and sometimes that
first step is the hardest of all gave
you is because we're really excited
maybe it was because we're a little
naive since then I've learned how easy
it can be to get discouraged to give up
or let go of something and I've learned
because of that that if you could take
that first step that you can decide
you're going to do something no matter
what the rest becomes a lot easier so
anyway so after a few months of
designing the yearly plans for our
garden I'm fundraising raising money
writing grants we planted a 3500 square
foot garden over that first summer we
donated over a thousand pounds of
produce to low-income shelter families
around the area and to shelters we
brought in kindergarten classes to learn
in the garden we taught high school
biology classes in the garden when we
came back to school in the fall we tried
our salads out in the cafeterias then
over the last 23 groans about two
growing seasons we've tripled the size
of the garden it's not 12,000 square
feet we've also put in 26 hour loop
fruit trees built two sheds and a
full-size greenhouse we now have every
day multiple classes come down from all
three schools in our district to learn
in the garden in the fall we do three
days a week and all three cafeterias we
serve our vegetables and in the spring
we do two days a week and we're about to
start we've raised over $80,000 in the
last four years and in the beginning we
had three kids involved we've now had we
now have a board of twelve students and
an advisory board
100 so that's my story it's pretty
simple but just kind of why no
please it's really easy to elicit that a
cosmic of that applause because you
don't know about all the horrible
mistakes we made its way out number the
success of C so that story is simple and
that's why I was kind of thrown when
this kid turned up to me and said can a
kid change the world in one kid change I
was thinking about what's happened over
the last four years and actually the
drive from my house to Pinellas pretty
link so I had a lot of time to think
about this question and I think I've
answered my answer is that first
changing the world has to happen one
care that's time it's messy you make
mistakes it's slow it's tedious it's
tiring that first year I told you we got
classes to come down to the garden but
it didn't happen like that it wasn't
that easy what happened was all the
faculty were like no way we're
overloaded we have too much dude there's
no way we're adding extra stuff on our
place to bring kids down to some garden
so we're like okay okay that's fine
fully understand your lot to do so what
we did was at the beginning of every
week we went to all the mailboxes in the
faculty lounge and each week we put a
different vegetable in the mailbox so
the first week we filled all the
mailboxes with cherry tomatoes and the
second week we filled all the mailboxes
with carrots and whee bye week nothing
happened no response people ate the
carrots and tomatoes the radishes but
eventually one teacher said hey thanks
so much for all those all those
vegetables and you know I was thinking I
might bring my class down to the garden
is that cool you guys we're lecture and
then
few days later another teacher said hey
you know my friend went out of the
garden you know mrs. Sullivan and she
said it was great can I bring my class
down the garden and like I said now we
every day we have multiple classes
working god it's slow its tease it's one
vegetable at a time the same thing
happened with our cafeteria we were
determined we had this dream of getting
our food and cafeterias and we thought
it'd be easy you know you just grow the
food you bring it up the cafeteria and
they serve no doesn't happen at the head
of the Food Service Program kathy was
not happening she is used to just
heating up packaged foods that are
frozen and that's all she has to do
there was no way she was going to take
dirty crooked vegetables and have to
wash them and cut them and prepare them
there's no way she's going to do that so
every week that first year we emailed my
family emailed her with a list of what
we had so I read every Saturday she'd
email and say we have this many pounds
of greens as many pounds of carrots this
many tomatoes and every week Kathy would
write back and say sorry not interested
we don't want to use your produce and
every week Natalie Wood today okay
that's fine and the following week
should send to the list again finally
after about four or five weeks of this
happening I think Kathy was just fed up
with it she was like okay fine we'll try
a salad take some of your green take
some of your cucumbers we'll do one
salad in the luncheon I'm sure at her
head that was it and we give up and we'd
be satisfied you know lost high
schoolers so easily satisfied and what
happened was that day we came early at
6am we harvested tons of food we brought
it up the cafeteria we announced that on
a lot of speakers you know today the
food that you guys grew in the garden is
going to be in the cafeterias and
formal south and in our school on an
average day the cafeteria cells between
four and six hours that day yeah rafa
that day with the project sprout food
they sold over seven and kathy was
hooked and again like i said now we
serve our food three days a week in the
capture it takes patience it takes
understanding that it's not going to
happen like like right away it's going
to happen slowly it's going to take a
lot of people saying no over and over
and over again it's going to have to
happen one care at a time the second
thing that change in the world takes is
gardening in the rain two years ago 2009
I don't know if you guys remember or
heard about it but there's something
called 350 day and 350 day was supposed
to be the biggest day of environmental
action in history it was organized in
the fall and people from all over the
world we're going to gather and hold up
signs and gather in big masses and and
write out the number 350 which is an
important number in terms of parts of
carbon in the atmosphere and it was
really exciting I helped organize an
event in my town that was going to
happen we're all going to organize do
something to do the number 350 and it
was a Saturday and Saturdays are our
work days and so that Saturday we were
also planning to build our greenhouse we
had gotten a grant for seven thousand
dollars to build this greenhouse we're
really excited because he was going to
allow us to grow our food for the
cafeteria even in the winter but it was
fine because I was going to show up in
the garden at seven in the morning we're
all going to build the greenhouse be
done by three o'clock and then I was
going to go to this really exciting
event in for the 350 we get to the
garden and first of all it's pouring
rain it's like 40 degrees just pouring
we started out with like 30 volunteers
which is great but by like 10 a.m.
that's down to violence because people
were sick and coughing and cold and
uncomfortable and we're missing all
kinds of parts everything was missing
things were mismatched the drill didn't
work but the generator didn't work it
was just all falling apart by 1205 we
have gotten one
i Coupe up for the entire who passed by
three o'clock we're not supposed to be
leaving for this really exciting 350 day
it was down to three volunteers and we
were about halfway done by seven o'clock
the Sun was going down we were putting
the other the last few pieces of the
hoop house we got it done I went home I
was exhausted I pinch were raped I was
covered in mud and my hands were numb
and I just fell asleep I woke up the
next morning and my email was flooded
with emails from these organizations all
over the world but pictures saying you
know yesterday was the most important
day in the history of environmental
action you know everyone will be telling
their grandkids about this the day we
all stood you know together you know for
this for the environment and there were
emails from people in my community all
where were you yesterday was so awesome
is the best day in the history of great
barrington you know what a wonderful day
and I kicked myself because I spent the
day struggling in the coal bin Laden to
get up together the soup pots I kicked
myself for missing what could have been
the most important day in my life as an
environmental activist some days will be
rewarded with Pat's on the back
congratulations people tell us how proud
they are what a good job but most days
will struggle in the mud when no one is
watching most days will argue with
people about the value of local food or
the environment most days we won't get
rewarded with Pat's on the back we'll
just work and no one will notice and
it'll be worth it if I could go back
that day and leave the garden at three
o'clock and go to this 350 thing and not
finished it about I wouldn't because
we're not one step closer to serving our
food year round in high school capture
sure everyone else be telling their
grandkid about the time they they you
know stood up and with 350 people and
all over the world and celebrating this
day but i'll tell my grandkids
time I stood knee-deep in mud screwing
together a few pieces of metal to change
the world you have to be willing to
guard in the rain and finally and by far
most importantly to change the world we
need kit i have a strict rule I don't do
talks in the summer really I'm a farmer
I'm not a speaker and so in the summer
is time for working in the garden and
working on the dairy farm it's not time
for speaking but it's jun 28 and I'm
here and that's because this is a room
full of kids high school you know
there's the this is my this is the end
of my type of project about I just
graduated and so leading up to the lack
in the last few weeks I was determined
to make it be the best kick off to a
growing season ever and I just thought
if the growing season could get off to a
good start the project's probably fine
so the for the rest of its time and they
wouldn't eat me and everything would go
smoothly and a few weeks ago things were
not going smoothly we had to bail with
all hundred beds we hadn't even started
weeks behind schedule and everything was
just going horn and and so one day
finally we're still behind but we're
going to get started to build a few bed
me and my friend Lord went to the garden
to build the beds and we were there we
got on our shovels five minutes later
Lauren is like oh man I got bad news we
forgot we have a meeting for our
fundraiser today we can't start on the
beds so I was like okay fine i will put
the shovel away the right then i see a
car pulling up with the garden and a
first I don't recognize the card I
realize what it is it's the car of this
kid joint this kid George coca fur and
George Gophers captain basketball teams
of junior and he's never been to the
garden and I was sure I would never see
him in the garden George Beaufort pulls
up and he gets
you guys hey guys what's up I have a
doctor's appointment a little bit i'm
here to help I got some time to kill
we're like sorry George but we're
leaving we actually got to pack up his
stuff through maybe next time thanks for
stopping by and George looked at us for
a second he's like not really though I I
have some time to kill can you just
leave me a shovel and dig a few beds so
we said okay we gave him a shot when we
left the Lord and I went to our meeting
in our meeting was about two hours long
and about 6 30 we leave the meeting and
Lauren's like oh man I forgot my cell
phone at the garden you gotta go back so
we drive back garden as we're pulling up
I see George Gophers coffee and I get
out of car and I look up and sure enough
there's George poker at the other at the
other end of the garden working on his
20th head down hand on a shovel the next
morning was a was the was a community
garden day and I wasn't really expecting
a lot of people I showed up at around
nine a.m. and Dawn was there I thought
ok ok that's fine because there's a big
party the night before and I figured
every was sleeping in but around eleven
o'clock I see a bunch of kids and track
uniforms coming over to the garden and
one of the kids come down communities
like hey George Cooper said you guys
needed help building bet so we brought
the track team sounds like okay sure
and a little while later see the
baseball team how many over the guard
and once again someone comes up is like
yeah we heard you guys needed help every
was talking about it so he came to help
build bets I want to block all 100 beds
were built and we were two weeks ahead
of schedule that's how it works
that's how things get done went into the
ball you got high school thing there
that's how things get done sometimes it
takes a year to build the hoop house you
thought was going to take you a week
other times it takes you a day to build
the bed probably take you a month I one
last story last summer I was I was at an
interview at my high school it wasn't a
work day in the garden so I wasn't
working in the garden but i had to get
picked up on my mom and it's easier her
to pick me up in the garden so I went
out of the garden just get picked up and
as I'm walking down I see a mom and her
little kid walking around the garden and
I thought maybe they were there to buy
t-shirt or ask for some vegetables for
the win over and asked if they needed
any help and the mom said oh I like
sorry were it's just that my son is in
the after-school program and and every
time we drive by the garden his I hominy
mom you look the garden can we stop and
I never stopped so today I thought I
would stop and let him show me around
the garden like hope you don't mind and
so I said sure no I don't mind I'll just
I'm just waiting for ryan I'm gonna go
sit on the edge of the garden and don't
mind me and I realized I recognized the
kids his name's Parker Haines and he's a
four-year-old Lu Xun one of the
after-school programs and so I sat on
the edge of the garden and watched as
Parker Haines led his mom around the
garden out of toilet all I couldn't see
him the whole time because everyone's
while he'd disappear under the
because he's about this big and so he's
leaving his wall around the garden and I
could hear some of the things he's
saying not everything but some of the
things I can hear him say look mommy
these are my carrots and we plant them
the pic with the tomatoes as they grow
all together and look mommy these are
beans and potatoes and I plant them that
way cuz their friends and so far cry
aids these his mom in this tour and
finally she's like--she's done with
torches okay all right time to go down
they decide to leave the garden but as
they're walking out there badly and he
reaches up and grabs his mom at his moms
Hannigan he stops he looks up at her
with this look out space if the look my
cousin gets whenever she tries on a
dress and like asked her mom what it
looks like it was this worried
expectancy the Parker looks up at his
mom he says mommy do you like my garden
I thought about that and I looked out of
this 12,000 square foot garden and I
looked down at Parker hands and I
realized he's one hundred percent
correct it is his car and that's why
kids matter the kids matter because a
four-year-old who comes up to my knee
can feel ownership over 12,000 square
foot garden and a group of high
schoolers that every single adult out
there think spends the whole their whole
time playing video games and can't
commit to anything group of high
schoolers can feel ownership over the
world and decide that they're going to
change it and make it the right place
that they want the future to look like
so the whole time we've been talking
I've had this photo up in the background
and it's a nice photo that's from the
gardens kids sunny day and that photo
sort of captures the stories and it's an
important story I think it's
story it's the story about you know the
deliciousness of a tasty vegetable it's
a story about the relaxation of working
in the garden on a sunny day it's a
story I would tell a room full of little
kids it's the story I would tell a room
full of potential donors probably even a
room full of adults but you guys are a
room full of high schoolers and the
story that I want you to leave today
remember it is this story
that's the story of trying to change the
world one care at a time as TV isn't
tiring painful as it can sometimes be to
work that's loaded it's the story of
gardening in the rain and the snow and
the cold when all you you're just
craving warm and sunlight and comfort
it's it's the story that if I told my
grandmother that I was going to talk to
you guys about today should be like oh
great now none of them are ever in the
garden in their lives um but I more
faith in youth and kids than my
grandmother does because I know that
it's a story that we're going to have to
live if we want to change the world and
it's the story that only you only
awesome only us are going to be able to
carry out in order to make change so
four years ago i started a garden I've
said in that sentence so many times now
and each time I say it the length of
time it's a little longer the first time
I said you know six months ago i started
a garden and i was talking about a small
50 x 70 pot at my school I just finished
my freshman year of high school and a
few weeks ago I graduated after working
in the garden every day for four years I
only have a few weeks left in the garden
and there are a lot of things I'm proud
about I'm proud of that Shaunie
Rodriguez decided that he like sweet
peas I'm proud that the cafeteria
workers noahcorp obvious and I'm proud
that dozens of other schools have
started project perhaps but the thing
I'm most proud of is that a few weeks
when i leave projects crowd there won't
even be a hiccup in its operation and
when I come back to visit a few years
down the road no one will recognize
someone will have any idea who I am so
just hand your shovel and asked me to
start taking the truth is I haven't
changed the world in the last four years
but what I've realized is that if people
like George co prefer keep staying late
at the garden to dig beds okay kids like
Parker hangings decides that it's their
garden and all of us are willing to
garden in the rain then I don't have to
change the world the change will be
enough
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu